[音楽]
new open
みなさんこんにちは
年長じゃないですかこんばんは
今日は触覚触った感覚ですね
それについてお話をしたいと思います
ちょっとその前に一つ簡単な質問をさせてください
右手を左胸にあててみてください
当たり前ですよねー
生きてるから心臓が動いてその動きをこの右手に感じることができる
しかしこの当たり前のことを皆さん史上どのくらい考え時間があるでしょうか
心臓というのは生まれてからずーっと数十年
そして24時間365日ずーっと動いています
寝ているママを見ているままん
日本館2号 l 6血流を
から中に印を打っているんです
僕も含めてこのことを実感しているということはなかなかないかもしれません
そこで今日はこのような心臓の働きだったりとか
居抜きのことを実感するそのような装置を持ってきました
[音楽]
これは心臓
テクニックという装置です
こちらの挑戦記を運命に当てるとこの真オーガ取ることを得てます
そしてこちらの海ので音を振動に変えます
そしてから振動がこの白い歯考
心臓ボックスと言いますけれどこれが震え出します
なのでこれを歌になっていると思う
これは神童顔でながらコース体制が難しいですけれども
とても早いですその品長をしています
で
実はですねこれ先ほどダンスをスタートだったらもっと早くなるでしょうし
で恋愛なとをもっとゆっくりかもしれません
さらに面白いことにしばらくこうやって持っていると思う
袋の中の心臓が
ここに出てるような気すらします
この線とわー
実は記録することもできるんです
今はちょっとありますけれども
ここで撮ったその像がここに記録されてこちらの心臓ボックスが
自動的に振動はずではそうするとこうやって両手で悶える
そしたら誰かにあげたらいいのかそういうこともできます
さらに
ここでですねこれを抜いてしまう
この振動が止まるわけですね
この時
とてもせつない気分だ
寺尾上ドキドキドキドキしていたものが今日も止まってしまうと
なぜか僕らわー
と喪失感に襲われます
も年取った
このすんぞんピクニックというのは
だ
やはりの前の通りたくさんの人と一緒にワークショップな形で会社員をしています
例えばですけれども子どもたちが
自分の心臓を触ったり人の尊像触ったりしながら命の大切さを学んだりしています
それだけではなくて
子供大人お年寄りをたくさんの人が集まっている
おさわりあ
例えばですけど今日いらっしゃるかは分かりませんけれども
お腹にもし墓さんがいたとしたらうえお
中にあてるときと上に破る時で違う振動って感じることができます
このようなの
この食感
てに仙蔵持つということは命の実感を私たちが開けることができる
こんな装置にな
性格なんで
この緊張している僕の仙蔵ドアだから触っていただきたいなと思ってるんですよ
そちらの方をお願いしていいですかで書くラーメンと梅肉に上がっていただけます
入っちゃった
ちょっといけないですよ
社会の日生の頃
結構ないですよ
ありがとうございます
ちょっと受付かもしれないですけれども見てますかね
なる実はわたしは母親
それは言葉で話しをするんですけれど
心臓はたしてコミュニケーションをとるってなかなかありがとうございましたん
どうもありがとうございましただけ
th
いいだけです
仙蔵を待たすとか心臓を交換するということはどういう意味があると
普段送られたカーンとはじめまして
日本人は得意ですけど名刺を渡しますよね
まず名前を交換するつまり自分の希望を交換することでだんだん親しくなりと握手をし
たりとか
は苦労したいところ
だんだん進退的な情報を交換しましょう
しかしこちらの場合はいきなり自分の一番大事な心臓を渡すわけですね
そして
ああどうもあせません戸惑ってしまうわけですけれども
そういうコミュニケーションの間かっ
今までだんだんだんだん希望的なところから新たいときに変わっているような
コミュニケーションというのをいきなり
新堆肥などから始める
そんなことができるんじゃないかという機械です
では次
この触覚の馬頭のプロジェクターについてお話をしたいと思います
次のプロジェクトは
上言葉に関するプロジェクトです
下記ことはそれは下記言葉ですね話し言葉の
私がしていることです
上言葉というのは増える振動によって言葉を作ろうというプロジェクトです
これは受賞には載ってません
は暇ではないですね私が考えをつけました
そこでこの震え言葉を作るプロジェクトをしています
そのつついてお話をさせてください
そのプロジェクトでは少し特殊な振動を使っています
それはこちらにあります
新体感2錯覚コミュニケーションを何というか分からないと思いますけれども
自分のお腹と背中に振動スピーカーというをつけます進路するそうですね
それをお腹背中の順番で少し時間差をつけて不動産にあります
グループとそうするとお腹にょた気がするという錯覚がショーします
つまりグループルっと震えるとそこにギュンとなるんじゃないかお腹んきたっていう風
に感じるわけで
このようなちょっと特殊な振動を使って売れ言葉を作る
そういうことをやってみるプロジェクトをやってい
では本当に宇部言葉を作ることができるのでしょうか
3ではなくてご紹介したいと思います
聖魔ことを言っているんです
間通信
欧米10日
先ほどの貫通食感を作るベルトですね
この付録この2つのどれかを押すと一つアイテム進路が受けられます
の時は
ほとんど見えないか里の大きい
梅のマゾ相手に何が遅れていると思います
[音楽]
そんなことを実現
元開発されて
品名の最近に使われないこういう使い方も前ということで打って
俺もはようで a
a
うん
かんっ
買う
google で県らしいんですね
ここで行われていただくことどういうことかというとボタンを押すとありて新郎がいき
ます
その中でこの場合はフック種類の振動を順番にいろいろ選べながら空いてるよー
ということをしてみまし
日本語では
音馬が刺さるといういまー者がありますけれども
このまえませんボタンをことが吹く去って飾るんですね
言葉というよりは振動が刺さるわけです
そういうことをしてみたわけ
ただこれ先ほどの目でおいしいんですけれども
注目していただきたいのは本年笑いが起こっているということなんですね
他二人は
特にしゃべるしていません会話はしていません
だけれどもボタンを押して振動を送っているだけなのもなぜか来ないが思うんですよ
っていうのは2人の間で文脈が共有されていないと笑いというのは起こらないわけです
の場合は私が彼に遅刻して米
ツンツンって送ってここでめっちゃあって帰ってきたんだちょっとダメな謝罪が受け
られなかった
これはられる
これはのう
文脈を共有できるようなのはなにかを考え校
北にある事で一つの会話のような
が成立数の緩和もしれない
そして
もう一つ別の方ですけれどもこの場合ん
2人
は改札そうですから
実は我々は
ググったらあげるときそれが誰なのかによってもそのメッセージを組み合わせ方を変え
ますし相手が親しい書だったら姉という伝わり方が優しくしたりもしかしたら知らない
人だったらもっと柔らかくするかもしれません
思う
実は明示的にしなかったとしても
心体的な本というのは我々は自然に使っているわけです
そしてここでご紹介した上言葉というのは実は触覚の言葉というのは目が見えなかった
としても
海が聞こえなかったとしても相手に伝えることができる
そんなものじゃないかと思ってい
では最後に
なんで僕がそんなことをやっているか
簡単にお話をさせてください
普段僕らが周りの情報近鉄というのはまたに毎日ですがもう見たりパソコンいたり
たくさんの情報が送られてきています
そして僕が同オイル風に検索をしたか何を張ったかによって
これはいかがですかーとかこのもんかいませんかところいろんな情報が送られてくる
わけですね
これね何もパクそんなこともあったりします
プロという間と問う言葉を換えれば
恩恵たのかを人間をことを制御しているという風に言うこともできますし
地下したら性状態というのは人間にとっては放牧ではないのかもしれない
ふうも思い始めました
そうであるならばとは
少し違った編方物事情報から自分で君を発見するようなやり方っていうものが必要なん
じゃないかと思って
つまりたくさんの情報が来た時
完全にじゃあこれやればやればやればじゃなくってこれは自分にとって重要なとか自分
にとって価値があるということを自分自身で判断する
僕は自分自身で反応する時間
ということが必要なんじゃないかなと思います
ました
そうなと思う
どうやったら良いだろうと思ったんですけれどもも一つとして
人の体を張っていうものに注目してました
人の体は生まれてからずっと何か自分か気持ちいい気持ち悪いいればこれは実に貼る
意味とか
そういう自分の価値判断の歴史をずっと一緒に体験してきた理由
それであるならば何か情報を受け取ったときに小さくかもしれませんけれども
反応しているわけですね
だったらその戦隊の反応というものをうまくサポートしたりいろんな情報技術というの
が必要じゃないかなと思いまし
言葉を変えるとですけれども
資格だったりとか小学というのはそこに何かがあるということはよくわかるんです
けれどもなかなか
とに感情を伝えることができない
心を動かすことはそこまでできないかもしれません
一方で先ほどご紹介した
心臓手に持ったりとか触覚ず分で受ける
その中から何がコミュニケーションをするそういう過程というのは
船体が反抗する支援サポートになるんじゃないかと
まあここで情報技術にとってねハッ献血量ですよねと言ったんですけれども
実はもう少しいうと生きている踊っている
つまり何かこうゴールがそれだけに向かって達成して終わりじゃなくて毎日のセンター
その中で新しいことを発見する
もしかしたら自分を発見すれば自分でこういうことできるんだと
自分て考えたのかもしれないということを発見したり
さらに汗かいはこんな風にネップができるんだということを発見する
そういうことは僕らが生きていることなんじゃないかなと思っています
そして
その生きているため後に白点にはある
触覚情報書を書くかするとかそれだけじゃなくて
私たち人間自身が触覚に対する感受性を持ったりとか触れることでできる動画がに表現
するのか誰よりソルヒョンさも触覚の表現がよく見ますとか
そういう能力を
これからこれが持っていることが重要じゃないかと思う
以上で僕の話思いますありがとうございました
[拍手]